what inspired you to look for a low carb
option
i am living with type 1 diabetes
and therefore i have to restrict my
carbs so pilar take it away what are we
doing today so today we're doing
actually our take on a shepherd's pie so
what we're doing today is sort of
revisiting that playing with the ratios
making it more vegetable forward
and doing some smart and delicious
substitutes gina that hopefully you and
your family can enjoy so the first thing
we're going to do actually is we take
cauliflower
and celery and we've boiled that until
completely tender and what we're going
to do is puree that drew we're going to
have right beside you i think you have a
little bit a little bit of butter into
that
and a little bit of lemon zest and this
puree is basically going to act as the
mashed potatoes so we're going to puree
that really quickly
[Music]
[Applause]
there we got it
thank palar yeah the texture we're
looking for is like close to mashed
potatoes it's going to be a little bit
of a little bit looser because of the
cauliflower and this is another trick we
like to do is we're going to use that
puree two ways we're going to put it
into the filling mix and on the topping
so in this pan it smells so delicious
right now we've got sauteed celery leeks
and carrots
and then we have cauliflower we have
mushroom that's going to give you that
deep flavor umami umami and chard and to
this we're going to add a little bit of
thyme
tomato paste
and worcestershire sauce that's very
hard to say i know i just heard ming and
that's how i feel too and that
the tomato paste and the worcestershire
is gonna give you that really deep
comforting savory flavor
and then we're gonna
pop in
half a pound of ground turkey okay so
typically this dish is made with
lamb or beef here we're going to lighten
it up and use some ground turkey which
is very very lean
and then drew you have your puree in a
bowl on the side and as i said earlier
we're going to use it two ways so this
is one of the tips and tricks that we do
a lot we're going to fold in a cup just
one cup of that vegetable puree so this
dish usually has cream in it
it has dairy this vegetable puree is
gonna sort of like make a mock version
of that thicken it get it nice and
creamy
and then we're gonna
scoop some of that mixture
into the ramekin
a little ramekin over here
and then
you're going to put
the rest of that
puree
of cauliflower
and celery which is super delicious and
you're gonna dollop that on top and what
you do to this is again like using
ingredients you know like fat carbs salt
like our body actually needs that to be
healthy it's about using the ingredients
smartly and deliciously you're going to
sprinkle some cheese on top just a
little bit you're not loading it up
you're not loading it up but you're
still going to get that flavor and we're
going to pop this into the broiler at
400 for how long seven to ten minutes
until it gets golden on 407 to 10 i need
those details and if i don't remember
them i'm not going to attempt the dish
i'm already flustered enough
like sexy in the kitchen i am not but a
food lover i am all right and when it
comes out that's what it looks like
that's what it's so beautiful it's
really beautiful
um let me pop over one over here little
finishing topper
we're gonna sprinkle fresh parsley
i mean come on pilar mama amazing fresh
pepper and we have one for gina
is all about too gina
i want to see if this fuels your rocket
so to speak
thanks drew and pilar gina
so excited
that's hot i need the bottom
oh thank you thank you so much all right
one day
bon appetit yes
you know what do you think yes oh my
gosh
very good
i can make this
i can make this
oh my god
oh my god
i thought it was going to be good this
is way better
than i thought it's light it's really
satisfying it hits all those notes this
actually also freezes up really nicely
you can park it in the freezer when you
have guests then throw it in the oven to
heat up
the full recipe
is on the website the drewberrymore
show.com
[Applause]
[Music]